yes big sexy in the building the hood
hottest princess what's up what's going
on uh first of all congratulations
you've had a quite the uh last few
months with pound town going absolutely
crazy thank you it is uh it is a moment
it is for Real it is it reminds me I
don't even know what it reminds me of it
reminds me of like some two live cruise
ship back in the day or like yeah I'm
glad you compared it to that yeah like
it's a pretty crazy record yeah people
are saying freak neek and stuff yeah I'm
like well though I don't understand
um I don't know that's it yeah I don't
know uh for you uh give me kind of like
a little bit of your like uh backstory
like like how first of all how long
you've been rapping
um I've been rapping for like four years
now it's probably finna before yours so
kind of like right before the pandemic
started you yes yes yes yes yes right
before and then that's when
[__] were stuck in the house
not just making some and you were making
songs
um what what like how did you grow up
what were you doing before music before
music I was doing her I used to be just
selling [__] like when I was young I was
a little slide sell some candy anything
I could sell but the last thing I was
doing before I became famous or whatever
was I was a hair stylist so you were
selling people's hair around St Louis no
I was doing everybody hair like
everybody here I was the hood hottest
hair stylist okay so everybody would
come to you get their [__] right
everybody knew I was like for real like
I was the one that did the hair the
right way like now my friends be calling
me like man I wish you still do her
don't nobody do her like you like all my
old clients they still wish I did her I
was like no now so how do you get your
hair stylist if you're a hair stylist
you gotta like have a real you do your
own [__] yeah I do my own oh that's fair
but but sometimes when I have to get my
hair done and I just don't got time and
they like sexy you can't do your hair
you can't do everything we gotta get
somebody then I just be like all right
find me somebody you know you have a ton
of tattoos yeah uh you you have your
whole situation situated over there too
yeah how painful was that uh it didn't
even hurt like
um I used to like pain when I was young
I got them a lot of these when I was
young okay what was the most painful
tattoo you have my chest or my neck the
neck
at the butt hurt too because it's like
it make you clench your ass right like
you it's like you're getting stabbed in
the butt oh when I say that hurt the
whole time I was just clenching my ass
she's like oh
and this is new the sexy on the yeah I
just got the on the um where was we was
in Memphis a little Memphis trip you say
you know what let me get another face
tat I love it I love face tattoos
um yeah you've kind of like you don't
look like you got nothing for real I do
you do I got well I got my wife's name
right here okay that's cute my friend
just got her baby daddy name on her
finger and then I I got I got stuff
under my shirt oh you do I got my back
done
yeah I got to see your back cause I love
back tattoo do you yes I want my back it
hurts I know the back hurts for sure I'm
a numbing